gut 20 jahre steht monaco pitchen und
schon hier am zerr ferner lift und für
jeden der den berg hinauf kommt hat der
ein freundliches wort
der schönste arbeitsplatz der welt sagt
er schauen sie nur auf das panorama
macht mir spaß mit leuten
zusammenarbeiten wie wir froh wenn er
eine starke tag vorbei ist ohne unfall
ohne probleme rooney kam als flüchtling
mit seiner familie während des
bosnienkrieges jähriger ins
kleinwalsertal und er ist geblieben
heute sagt er
ist das hier sein zuhause das
kleinwalsertal 5000 einwohner und
hunderttausende von touristen jedes jahr
eine landschaft wie aus dem bilderbuch
schon vor monaten hat die gemeinde
angeboten hier wieder flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
ich glaube es sollte ja nicht als
pflicht sondern als
selbstverständlichkeit gesehen werden
dass wir menschen aufnehmen und wird die
neuen solidarität mit den anderen
gemeinden ländern und auch im staat
selbst ja nur bisher ist kein flüchtling
gekommen und das hat bürokratische
gründe nur diese eine straße führt ins
kleinwalsertal und die kommt aus
deutschland
deshalb kann die österreichische
regierung auch keine flüchtlinge zum
beispiel aus wien schicken
denn die müssten dann erst durch bayern
um ins kleinwalsertal zu kommen und das
wäre illegal
immerhin eine familie soll jetzt anfang
oktober kommen ins pfarrhaus das steht
seit zwei jahren leer
pfarrer konrad kater macht sich keine
illusionen nicht alle seine schäfchen
werden sein angebot gutheißen vermute
dass es zweierlei meinungen gibt warum
gerade flüchtlinge warum nicht
einheimische familien aber die not ist
sollte in erster linie maßgebend
aber die bereitschaft zu helfen ist groß
orts dem platz ist reichlich im
pfarrhaus aber das eine oder andere muss
noch renoviert werden
kirche gemeinde und ein freiwilliger
helfer kreis teilen sich die aufgaben
jasmin hat den helferkreis im tal
mitgegründet für die bürokratischen
hürden flüchtlinge ins kleinwalsertal zu
bringen hat sie angesichts der notlage
nur wenig verständnis
es ist leider jetzt auf politischer
ebene nicht geklärt und ich bin jetzt
einfach froh dass dann zumindest diese
familie mit asylstatus zu uns kommen
kann wer da helfen können der lift an
dämonie arbeitet gehört zur sonne alb
viele kommen hier herauf um die sonne zu
genießen
hochbetrieb auf der hütte arbeitskräfte
sind gesucht in der gastronomie warum
also nicht flüchtlinge beschäftigen
doch moniz chef macht sich keine
illusionen monierte paradebeispiel bei
integration
super lässigkeit in ihrem momentanen
wenn sie nicht deutsch können sind es
meistens nur sagt jetzt unter anderem
seien die hilfsjobs küche hilfsarbeiten
mit perfekten deutschkenntnissen ist
alles möglich ein flugblatt mit der
bitte um spenden für flüchtlinge rooney
und seine frau kasner werden nach
passenden sachen suchen jetzt muss man
seine hand ausstrecken sagen sie wie
damals für uns sie haben nicht vergessen
wie das kleinwalsertal sie seinerzeit
aufgenommen hat über 20 jahren sind
schon da am anfang war es nicht leicht
jahren zu kommen sagen sie nach allem
was sie erlebt hatten man müsse sich
schon auch von herzen integrieren wollen
fern der alten heimat in einer ganz
anderen welt